president biden signed a new bill into
law today with the goal of combating
hate crimes against
asian americans during the pandemic orco
mana tells us how the growing asian
community here in las vegas
hopes this will help make a major
difference
i was followed i was spit on i was
called numerous slurs
as kovit 19 started spreading in the u.s
last year unlv student ava carino says
someone attacked her just because she's
asian
made me feel anxious carino was filipina
american and never experienced something
like that in her life
but since then she's seen a wave of hate
crimes against asians
all over the country another asian
american was attacked or killed in the
streets and hearing that from my
grandparents hearing it on the news it's
like
when is this going to stop president joe
biden signing new legislation thursday
to stop the spike in violence against
asian americans the kovit 19 hate crimes
act aims to speed up the review of hate
crimes make it easier to report them
and expand public education campaigns i
think we're going in the right direction
leaders in the asian community here in
las vegas say they're now working to
figure out
what exactly the law will look like in
practice we've talked about
hotline for example we've talked about
counseling maybe we've talked about
education so all of those things factor
in but
we have to come up with a good plan
carino is cautiously optimistic
even though this bill was signed into
law we still have a long way to go
orco mana 8 news now